serge gainsbourg le moins qu'on puisse
dire de vous c'est que vous êtes un
homme riche je ne parle pas au sens
péculier du nombre mais nous venons
d'entendre la musique de vidocq la
chanson en vidocq une chanson vous avez
fait ouais qui ressemble à une vieille
chanson française ah bon les choses en
france est inquiète a aucune on dirait
un bang et chanson française qui a été
reprise bah il fallait se il fallait
s'adapter à l'époque toute façon j'ai
piqué la campagne bob dylan
oui c'est que leur est d'ailleurs votre
corps gisait vieilles chansons
françaises j'allais dire vieilles
chansons françaises ou américaines qui
massacrent marquis mahut la trophée du
gorille et à trouver l'origine les
épiques et quoi le talent jusqu'à 8000
la rythmique oui oui mais voilà les
bases du rock du blues
ça m'a fait penser à une chanson d une
chanson qui chante harry belafonte qui
est une chanson sur les bannières
précisément un bon voyez vous c'est mais
ça vous n'avez pas comme vous dites
piqué le thème mais c'est le même prix
ça m'a fait penser immédiatement
bon alors donc une chanson qui a l'air
d'être une des chansons françaises ou
américaines
et puis voilà que vous fabriquez ça
s'appelle comme ça
une chanson pour l'eurovision pour
minouche barelli qui s'appelle boum
badaboum et qui est dans le vent comme
on est et puis il ya eu and naana on en
parlera plus tard la comédie musicale
quelque chose qui me paraît paradoxal
avec vous c'est que quand on parle de
gainsbourg en duo et gainsbourg il est
en avance de dix ans sur son temps ce
qui est agréable
12la et que d'autre part je pense en ce
moment vous êtes le l'auteur compositeur
qui distribuait le plus de chansons à
tous les jeunes chanteurs actuels
est ce que c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
alors mes souvenirs par les paradoxes de
palox risques et moi je sais je fais des
exercices de style je m'adapte et pour
moi je fais des visions un peu plus
avant gardistes
ouais c'est simple je peux faire
n'importe quoi il ya une chanson pour
eux je suis à ricco comme je peux faire
une chanson
ancien nôtres pour moi trois styles
savoure semblait incertain faussaire de
génie mais ce livre d'une base oui et
qui d'autre part aurait du talent pour
eux mêmes et ça ce n'est pas ce qui
arrive aux possesseurs de génie en
général j'ai réalisé mi de bien mais ne
font rien d'original alors qu'est-ce que
je fais là j'étais pas je crois que vous
allez enregistré 33 tout ouïe
attendez-vous notre histoire de fou
c'est à la station
ça vous trouve d'une arête dans la gorge
et j'ai la convention comment
recommencer la pub a que je recommence
que jenny oui j'ai dit que vous êtes
comme cette faussaire de génie qui
peuvent timité beaucoup de style
certains faussaires en tableaux peuvent
imiter aussi bien vos velasquez courbet
et j'ajoute que vous êtes comme certains
faussaire de génie qui auraient du
talent aussi pour eux mêmes c'est à dire
une personnalité qui ne soit imitée
d'aucune autre même assez bien ce que
j'avais entendu elle empêche les salles
de marché
pourquoi c'est tellement drôle c'est
marrant très exact et aucune prétention
être moi même ce que je pratique la
chanson comme un divertissement c'est
tout le sens sans aucune prétention
parce que j'aimerais savoir c'est
pourquoi vous avez tenu absolument à ce
que je la répète affirmation dans les
mêmes termes
ça a été affirmé
donc c'est plus considérer que c'est
assez flatteur vous voulez a donc vous
êtes content très content c'est
difficile d'obtenir cette affirmation du
goût mais ça fait plaisir